John Wick has some of the most insane
car crashes motorcycle crashes and
brutal assassination sequences you could
ever ask for in an action movie let's
talk about how they bring that to life
yeah the fall you know the one what if I
told you everything about the fall was
100 real and Keanu Reeves is more or
less completely made out of steel which
we know is true yes that's true well I'd
be lying but only kind of it wasn't
actually Keanu doing that stunt we have
to talk about Jackson's spiders
incredible performance in this scene
basically because the height of the Fall
was too high to shoot in one sequence
they had to split it up into sections
and put it all together with the visual
effects later the structures that he hit
really did Bend though they were made
out of rubber so they would bend with
impact the one thing that was a little
too accurate on that other hand was the
slam to the ground it was a little
harder and more realistic than intended
ouch Jackson's vital isn't the only one
taking hits for major stunts Keanu is
known for doing as many stunts as
possible even if they are incredibly
dangerous for a regular Hollywood actor
I'll definitely be getting more into
that later but for now I want to talk
about motorcycles this scene in chapter
3 was too much of a liability to not be
CGI doesn't make it any less sick though
the fact that it genuinely defies the
laws of physics makes it even more
entertaining in my opinion the scene was
inspired by a sequence in the movie The
villainess that both Keanu and director
Chad stachelski really like to
everyone's utter surprise the scene was
extremely difficult and dangerous to
shoot practically so they ended up
creating it with green screens and
locked vehicles on moving platforms so
basically Keanu and the rest of the guys
sat on bikes stationed on platforms that
were pushed around by other guys wearing
green suits it sucks they were trying to
mimic what they did on the set of the
villain s it wasn't as simple as we
thought it was it was a lot of work and
it was a lot of creative skill this is
tipping our hap to them the amount of
work they had to do for this scene was
actually insane the guys pushing the
bikes had to know the fight choreography
even though they weren't performing it
and they had to know the camera movement
so they could push the bikes accordingly
can you imagine telling people that your
job for the week is to push Keanu Reeves
around on a motorcycle while he hits
guys in the face not sure if I'm
qualified but I'm trying to apply carfu
if you know you know this scene in
chapter one was actually supposed to be
a lot more elaborate and intense but
they didn't have the budget for all that
according to Chad stachowski they were
about 10 cars too short to get the scene
they really wanted so instead they opted
for a fully practical scene where Keanu
Reeves gets to do some of his own stunt
driving or car bashing rather he took a
stunt driving course with Jeremy fry
where he learned how to do a sliding
drift with one hand and shoot his gun
out the window with the other which
might honestly be the most rad thing
I've ever heard of anyone doing like
ever where can I sign up to take a class
that teaches me how to do that would
certainly be a neat party trick to show
off to my friends or make being stuck in
traffic more fun in a safe manner of
course this is the opening scene for
John Wick 2. The Stunt Driver handling
the motorcycle is Joe Dryden and this
scene is for the most part completely
practical it was Joe's most difficult
scene he's ever done in his entire
career when the camera pans down to the
crash behind the scenes they've already
laid Joe and the Motorcycle down and
slid them down the road it took nine
takes to complete can you imagine having
to slide down the middle of the road
with a motorcycle nine freaking times
jump back up and take off full speed
these guys are living real life GTA out
here so here's another one that ended up
being way too dangerous to do
practically though Joe Dryden our
resident GTA stuntman really wanted to
do it self and actually argued for it so
yeah obviously that didn't happen so
instead they put a dummy on the bike
towed it into the door then topped it
off with a bit of CGI and voila no set
injuries who else was like super anxious
about how they were gonna clean up all
that glass in the end well apparently
nobody on set because most of it was
done with CGI this was in chapter 3
originally the glass cabinets were built
to explode on their own but they
couldn't get them to all explode at the
right time eventually they just ended up
narrowing down the movement with real
glass to only two one of them being when
a guy gets kicked into it causing it to
explode and the other is just a cabinet
on the lower level the rest of the
glasses like all digital but did you
know the glass was digital when you
first watched it who else is ready to go
out and buy a motorcycle after all this
no yeah me neither but I do love
watching creative people put together a
near impossible bike fight Keanu Reeves
drift cars with one hand and of course
we can't forget Joe dryden's GTA skills
so what do you think are some of John
Wick's best moments